gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
france 24 primero la quiero felicitar
por este reconocimiento y también le
pregunto cómo recibieron la noticia y
como la pandemia ha afectado a la
situación del hambre en el mundo
muchísimas gracias la verdad que nos
despertamos con esta noticia maravillosa
en un año que realmente ha sido muy
difícil para todos
estamos recibiendo este galardón los
17.000 trabajadores en todo el mundo del
programa mundial de alimentos que
estamos llegando a 100 millones de
personas necesitadas en casi 90 países
también por supuesto en américa latina y
el caribe y básicamente estamos notando
de que hay una relación directa entre el
conflicto y el hambre y que para poder
llegar a la paz realmente tenemos que
trabajar
en el hambre un elemento a veces
postergado pero felizmente este galarón
nos permite mostrar eso de frente el
hambre ahora hemos visto esta semana que
los ingresos de los más ricos del mundo
alcanzaron nuevos recursos durante esta
pandemia le pregunto cómo pueden
motivarlos a ellos a dar más ayudas más
contribución el objetivo de hambre cero
que ustedes plantean
si a medida de que suben los ingresos
también aumenta la pobreza y pobreza
extrema en nuestra región realmente la
emergencia de la pandemia y la crisis
socioeconómica que ha generado
llevado a millones de personas
adicionales hacia la inseguridad
alimentaria en muchos casos severa hemos
visto un aumento de casi el 400 por
ciento en nuestra región en américa
latina y el caribe muy preocupante estas
diferencias se tienen que salvar tenemos
que progresar en cuanto al desarrollo el
acceso a la educación y la salud para
realmente llegar al hambre cero ahora le
pregunto entonces cómo están trabajando
para lograr esta hambre cero en el mundo
estamos trabajando conjuntamente con los
gobiernos con nuestros socios
internacionales por supuesto con las
comunidades con el sector privado porque
definitivamente el desafío es enorme
estamos hablando de casi 700 millones de
personas en el mundo que padecen hambre
y solamente este año hemos llegado más o
menos a 270 millones de personas
afectadas por la pandemia y la crisis
entonces tenemos que impulsar mecanismos
y programas que ataquen el problema de
raíz los conflictos la guerra el cambio
climático la desigualdad la pobreza y en
eso estamos trabajando no solamente
nosotros en el programa mundial de
alimentos sino en las naciones unidas-
todas y con nuestros socios
definitivamente cuál es sus metas para
el año que viene el 2021
queremos realmente hacer un trabajo
consensuado juntos solidariamente para
poder llegar al hambre cero en unas
décadas por el momento estamos
trabajando en una emergencia y queremos
duplicar el número de gente que estamos
llegando aquí en américa latina y el
caribe y en otras regiones del mundo
donde hay conflicto como para poder
paliar la situación hay mucha gente que
lastimosamente no tiene que comer
come mucho menos peor y ese millones de
personas nos debemos todos ese es
nuestro objetivo ahora por último le
quiero preguntar cuáles son los países y
las regiones más afectadas los que más
padecen de hambre
definitivamente tenemos que hablar de
hiel en un país que está en total crisis
hay millones de personas al hombre al
borde de la hambruna el nivel más alto
de inseguridad alimentaria estamos
hablando también en áfrica en
situaciones donde hay huracanes o
tormentas grandes o sequías en nuestra
región también hay ti el corredor seco
de centroamérica la situación de
migrantes venezolanos en colombia y perú
en ecuador son muy preocupantes y en
este sentido tenemos que trabajar todos
juntos solidariamente para poder paliar
la situación mitigar la mucha gente
demasiada está sufriendo tiene hambre